I'm luk D and I work for re Creek
Partners which is Our Family Farm it's
comprised of my father and my uncle my
mother and myself and my wife um we run
a mixed Farm here grazing cropping and
livestock um my background I'm from
Precision farming and we're um yeah I'm
always trying to find the most
economical economical way to give the
greatest efficiency in what we do and
also be sustainable and look after our
land since the drought broke ended sort
of 2020 we um got a lot of rain and
we've had nearly four three to four
really really exceptional Seasons really
really wet that's bought some of its own
problems but every every time everything
brings problems but yeah we've had good
stock prices and yeah good yields good
livestock um and we' sort we yeah have
done reasonably well so we've decided
yeah to what we've made we're investing
back in to continue on to be able to
keep farming into the future and that's
through Water Works and fencing and
improving our pastures for the last
couple of decades I suppose we've moved
to minimum to no till mainly M till uh
improved pastures and Native pastures on
our grazing country and in the last
droughts or last couple droughts we
learned it was really important to
maintain ground cover and since then in
the last 3 to 4 years we've had high
rainfall and good pasture growth and um
very little water runoff in our
traditional dams and waterways and this
has decreased our ability to have
Livestock on country that does have
pasture but very very little water so
yeah we've decided
to put a couple of Bs together and put a
big header tank in and upgrade some
pipelines and add new pipelines and
Interlink all our farming country and
grazing country and start putting
troughs in it's a big task and yeah the
last couple years we've embarked on
doing that even through the dryer what
would have been Dyer pinches and spells
by having the rotational grazing being
able to
maintain the the feed body there and
have the water is definitely certainly
improving that we've noticed so we can
yeah continue our stocking rate through
the year instead of destocking and
restocking likewise so it's something we
want to keep doing more more work so we
can continue increasing our stocking
rate had some cropping country that
we're slowly breaking down into
rotational grazing country um and
they'll be they're basically 50 hectare
paddocks or more and we'll be splitting
them down into 20 hectare paddocks and
then whilst we're doing the fencing
we've been putting troughs in in the
fence line so they can be divided like
one one trough is being utilized between
two paddocks and that's sort of help
helping keep costs costs down a bit but
still providing the water there um
that's something we've done for a while
and yeah it's worked well so we'll
continue doing we live in our grazing
country lighter country and it's
traditionally that water runoff country
that's what you were talking about iron
bark country um Native grasses and we're
currently we're doing an Autumn our
terminal
use but join a terminal size uh are
laming down in that country at the
moment um and we wrote uh don't rotate
we sort of set stocked lamb but in small
mobs of 100 in Twins and singles so each
each Paddock on the Farm's getting
utilized and each padic needs to have
water but there's there's several
paddocks that we'll probably even go and
look at possibly that don't have any
water at the moment or just about to run
out of water with with uh Lambs at foot
on the U which is yeah it's not really a
good
situation I'd like to thank the local
Land Services for um providing
information and these updates
they're very helpful um they point out a
lot of things that are going on or what
other people are doing in the area that
we might not be doing or that what we
can learn on we try to attend most
programs that are run by the LLS AWI DPI
trying to always improve on what we're
doing because we can always do stuff
better trying to always improve our
1centers if you want to do something
there's plenty of contacts to talk to
and they've got good information and
there are resources that are there there
independent of of any major companies or
anything and they give out great advice
and it's something that we should we as
farmers and upcoming Farmers should
definitely support